غضب جمهوري بوجه اتفاق سقف الدين الامريكي
بعدما اعلن العديد من الجمهوريين في
الكونجرس الرفض التام لتسويه بايدن مكارسي
وصولا الى عدم التصويت عليها في الخامس من
يونيو المقبل السنه الجمهوري وهو من ابرز
المعارضين لهذه التسويه حذر منها بعدما
شكك باحكام الصفقه المتعلقه بالانفاق
الدفاعي مقارنه مع معدلات التضخم في
الولايات المتحده مشددا على ان الصفقه
تردد صدى كارثه العزل عام 2011 مما يهدد
الامن القومي للبلاد اما النائب الجمهوري
راراف نورمان فاعتبر بان هذه الصفقه ضرب
من الجنون لان زياده سقف الدين بقيمه
اربعه تريليونات دولار ستؤدي الى الافلاس
التام وبالتالي لن يصوت عليها بدوره
النائب دان بيشرب بان الولايات المتحده
سيكون لديها 35 تريليون دولار من الديون
في عام 2025 وهذا الامر غير مقبول على
الاطلاق ومن بين الاحكام الوارده في
الصفقه المبدئيه بقاء الانفاق غير الدفاعي
ثابت الى حد كبير خلال السنوات المقبله
ولن يرتفع في عام 2024 ويزيد بنسبه 1% فقط
عام 2025 ولتمرير الاتفاق مشاهدينا يجب ان
يصوت عليه مجلسي الكونجرس قبل الموعد
النهائي في الخامس من يونيو وبعد ذلك طبعا
ستتخلف الولايات المتحده عن سداد ديونها
لاول مره في تاريخها وتلا هذا الاتفاق
ردود فعل ايجابيه على العقود الاجله في
اسواق ولصت والاسواق العالميه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات